[MUSIC PLAYING]
My name is Daniel Hastik.
I'm one of the co-founders
of Futurelytics, and CEO.
Futurelytics is a
cloud-based solution.
And we help companies
to build relationships
with their customers
based on their behavior
so sales and marketing teams
can approach their customers
in the proper way, at the right
time, with the right products.
I guess, at the very beginning,
everyone is a little bit naive
and is getting more
and more professional.
So my role at the very beginning
was more about the product-- so
how this product can
help the end user, how
we can build that,
how we can scale it,
from a technical perspective.
And right now, it's more
about people and the balance
within and outside
of the company.
So I have to keep in
mind to whom, when,
and why is it important, for
example, to share our story
and to build the infrastructure
and door openings around us
before we actually
hit that wall.
For some people, it's
hard to distinguish
the value between
money and network.
The most valuable part for us,
to being within the Seedcamp
family, is the network of
the portfolio companies-- so
the openness of sharing the
stories between founders,
and especially, sharing
how this should not work,
and the best practices and tips.
And so that's our biggest--
it has the biggest
impact on the
business we have now.
I guess, when you
start a company,
always think about people
who have done that before.
OK.
Because that's the experience
which would be hard
learned by you, again and again.
OK.
There have been many,
many things done before.
And it's going on,
and on, and over.
It's just different technology
or a different market.
But always look for someone
who's a little bit ahead of you
and done all the mistakes.